gang don't forget to pick up your own
deck of the new Ru garbage card game
version 2 it's 50 new questions to find
out if your friends and your family are
trash oh yeah we also have tickets to
our New York show at Town Hall May 9th
available at rug garbage.com it's the
biggest show we've done today get the
tickets let's party gang yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trap
now here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at
they gr to be classy yeah just a big old
piece of trash trash trash I'm your host
stage Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at toties in the
new edition living high on the hog in
2024 baby we absolutely love it she's
upstairs mhm passed out okay what are
you going to do mhm some habits die hard
she tried real hard first couple days of
January resolutions down to drain my co
is coming at you from across the table
slightly amused this week he is the CEO
of Ru garbage he is an international
businessman and he happens to be my best
pal in the whole wide world lucky me
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody what up gang thanks for tuning
happy New Year gang uh we love you
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you revew subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are true cooking the
cooking uh then obviously patreon.com
you go over there you get bajillion
hours worth of content all your hard
feelings at bonus episodes Road videos
cribs videos the whole nine yards the
hot dog eating contest the big bucock
the the the Indie 500 the down aore
everything's on there check it out and
also Town Hall gang are you garbage.com
grab tickets yeah New York City biggest
show we've ever done it's going to be
sick it's a very nice place we'll
probably get thrown out some people will
definitely throw up and will be charged
for cleaning the carpets but check it
out it's going to be a good time and
there's probably a couple of cards left
over there at rug garbage.com if you
want to pick up the latest edition of
the rug garbage card game and how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the old magic man makes
us all look good works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours crosses the
te's dos the eyes sure T-Bone MC
scruffing Toby mcbow ladies and
gentlemen what up boys
nothing I'm feeling good feeling safe
especially with FY wearing his life
reserver appreciate that I got the life
jacket on we're having a good time that
thing I mean stunt my look dog is that
reversible no maybe I think it might be
no it's not okay all right cuz the thing
on the inside it's cool I like this
street wear Foley we got cooking here
LRG baby you look like you look like the
world's worst drug
dealer hey let me hold 20 what it's the
opposite of camouflage yeah I don't have
any baggie so just man I used to get
palmed to nug from time to time yeah I
got this it's just like a [__] you
know a little bit of shake mhm yeah uh
in the cellophane of a cigarette huge
that to me is was the best thing a
little seal it sure the lighter that was
the best vehicle for that cuz like you
weren't buying enough to fill the bag
dime bags I guess is all right you know
but you weren't filling enough to fill a
zip lock I like the nice clean sandwich
bag with the with the fold over the old
school that you lick yeah twisted up
real nice that's when we were doing
nuggies back in the day we were doing
swag Mexican brick weed M doesn't matter
what it came in sure come in a
pillowcase it's not going to get you
high
anyway it is it is yeah um I wanted to
ask you this because it is it is January
it is uh Rejuvenation do I like your
vest no it's resolution season all right
um do you remember cuz I was in Patty's
garage when we were home do you remember
your first piece of exercise equipment
like when you and your brother BBE
started getting of that age where like
you wanted to start working out and you
set something up in the garage we had it
I had it it was in my room for a little
while there was a there was a station
like in pasta
maker I got need the
carbs uh it was a very old stationary
but I'm talking like 70s stationary bike
I think the arm that was your first move
dude I mean that's not like I went out
and bought it what are you a single lady
in New York City I think it was my
trying to make it in a man's world I
think it was my stepdad's dad's and like
he brought it over dude this thing had
like an actual it had it was I'm talking
I meant like dumb bells an old workout
bench you had that that's CRA I guess
when he moved in he brought it over and
it was we set it up man you couldn't I
was like [__] I was like uh suzan
summers oh baby I had my butt was tun
yeah it was and we had it we it was just
like would you wear leggings when you
would
you showing off the games well after the
bike you get down on the handles with a
bunch of Springs yeah oh those were all
right too those were all right yeah
those were all right the the hand grips
no no no I'm talking about the hand
grips I know what you're talking about
yeah the thing that um tie up the kid in
The Goonies with Josh broland yeah they
tie him up with that he had this thing
didn't he Brolin in that the hand thing
they never made any sense to me he was
tight back then for tight now I loved
him back then I remember one time my my
my buddy's family in the basement they
had the very classic Suburban half fin
like three4 finished basement sure and
like it was a wall and then it was
unfinished storage the humidifier some
pump the boiler they had ACH old [__]
they had a big uh weight bench in there
like not bench system the one that had
like the pull down Universal huge and it
was it was in this was from like the
might have been from the 80s or early
90s so it was like a jungle gym and we
would go over there it's like 7 eighty
olds or whatever and like do we there'
be 15 of us like crawling in it and
every start
juicing putting up numbers I remember
one time it was like me and two other
kids were like hanging on like the the
thing and we' play with the weights we'
put all the weights up in like
counteract it and you could like hover
you know what I mean or like repel real
slow man trying to hurt yourself yeah
well I I broke this girl's fingers
bad yeah not on purpose not like she
didn't pay the veg and I was like you're
R uh she rode my exercise bike without
asking she went to like move it the
weight or something and me and another
guy were like you know descend there you
know and we let go or got off and Bam
like you know 80 lbs came down and
smashed her [__] up and you broke her
fingers yeah she was a gymnast it was
she was like a a Junior Olympic gymnast
and [__] like that and yeah damn ruined
her career I didn't know you had bodies
on you holy [__] don't cross this guy it
wasn't intentional there was no men's
Rea a crime of
passion uh no kidding yeah yeah it was
like super bowl or something we were all
in there just like [__] around
[__] around now if it's the thing
probably had pizza pizza grease on my
hands if I'm being honest I was out of
chalk that day now if you're thinking if
you're talking about the thing that I'm
thinking of um it's like a a rectangle
there's like a a a bench that comes out
like that but it's with stack plates and
then a couple different things around I
think that's called a universal I think
you're right you weren't banging with
those when you were in high school right
they had moved on from that [__] I guess
so yeah I don't yeah cuz that was our
first of all our weight room in high
school was literally just in the like
regular school hallway it was just a
class classroom yeah and had carpet and
everything and one of those things in
there and a bunch of dudes getting after
it everybody's [__] shooting up wind
strolling [__] still losing to Valley
High we beat
that cuz they got disqualified it was a
technicality but a win's a win it was a
pivotal time in the season half their
theme was
xcon it was always nice when some or
funny when somebody's dad started going
back when they you know cuz they maybe
they were like probably my age I
remember my dad doing that in cut off uh
you remember him like get trying to get
the band back together like all of a
sudden one day in the garage got the
weight bench over there we got this over
like very American Beauty Dads Dads are
all about big gut bench press
only we would go to one uh man it's so
funny I'm sure this guy's still
around he was like this Sports cuz my
brother uh my brother's a very good
athlete at the time like in high school
and and and uh like Junior High in high
school and stuff and so they were always
like you know he was always on all these
travel soccer teams and all this running
track and everything so he there was
this like local guy who used to be like
a strength and conditioning coach for
man this dude was something he looked
like he looked like an extra out of The
Sopranos dude he was like a strength and
conditioning coach and he would um some
squat
thrust I [__] hated that squat thrust
he had a real real rag tag operation
like in he was like it was just weird he
got some money together but from a
couple of investors smell this guy yeah
dude little cologne a little yeah
cologne in the gym he's got this he's
got slick back hair I forget his name
gold chain real Guido like and he had
the warm-up pants like the swishy you
know what I mean with the elastic at the
feet and the elastic up here they were
gray always gray to chain he he he's
doing squats going 200 weights 215 with
the
chains one
gabo how many reps you want to do about
10 Gaba gouls I would
say you want to do three sets of
moradell and three Gaba gouls so he we
went to my brother started going to him
for like you know like a weekend type
like Camp thing for like strength and
condition what [__] you were doing that
kind of stuff well I was going you
wer it was more of a it was more of a
strength and conditioning thing for
Danny more of my other son's a fat ass
let's whip them into shape see what the
gumball situation is meanwhile I was
probably eating Burger King on the way
over and [__] wait hold on where was
this at a Whopper in one hand and a
dumbbell in the other yeah where was
this
at like you know in my
area they got like a strip mall he had
like a little gym that was more of like
a like a industrial complex type like
business business parksh okay but it's
it's hard to describe there's like a
business SP it's it was in a garage it
was in it was in a commercial garage no
all right if I'm being honest when I
first started it was like connected to
the
hospital it was part of for when your
fat ass blows out of
hammy you were doing weekend physical
therapy
it was you're a basket in a pool like a
like a horse oh dude it's guys learning
to walk and kiy learning to
J I'm on the
[Laughter]
bars I think they might have had a set
of them now that I think doctor what
happened to that
[Laughter]
boy too many Lucky Charms fell in love
with chicken dendy at an early age I
can't do
it
holy [__] oh dude dude you know you're
out of shape when paralyzed guys are
talking
[__] but a little bit of help that fat
ass is going to learn to walk again one
day let me do it
myself [__] fat
ass I love it man you're sitting there
watching the other guy's
workout man you're probably getting
hungry working up a sweat just eating a
hospital
pudding I was promised ice
[Laughter]
cream dude man going and watching your
brother work
out that's funny so no so he we were
there it was either he was there and
then moved to his own place or was in
this place and then moved it wasn't um
it wasn't in the hospital but it was
like in the building of you know like uh
so it's obviously not the hospital but
like a five miles away there's like a a
hospital Camp another like satellite
campus Building of the might do like
Radiology there they might do I think
half of that building was a gym that's
Physical Therapy it was a physical
therapy I don't think I don't think it
was to be honest with you I mean the
hospital doesn't rent out [__] space
to [__] I don't think they were rent
I tiger
shman dude this dude was such a guido it
was coloscopy and kung
fu
no was he licensed I don't know he
definitely had his massage license
probably closing broads left and right
with that probably cleaned up in that
area he probably did Vinnie it was
something real uh but I started going
there my dad joined there I guess when
my brother joined my dad joined and it
was like a fitness thing I would go I
mean you know I didn't know what I was
doing I was I think I was work I think I
was working with him for a little bit
what do you mean like he was like
training no like training me I forget
man I wish I I I remember just being
there and I remember they had me running
one time with this like this like
college baseball player and we were like
cuz there was like an indoor track and
he had me running like Sprints down the
straights or something and dude I was
ready to throw up after like the second
one dude you were probably the rabbit
they probably probably told the baseball
player as many times as you can catch up
to this fat bastard no was just the one
kid it was you're basically the chicken
and Rocky chasing you around can't get
I'm covered in
butter can't get a hold of me baby I
stick and move when I feel
threatened I might be fat but I'm I'm
I'm
weary yeah you see that little fat kid
doing wheelies in the wheelchair that's
your pace car all greased up yeah that's
good but we never really did it in home
we went you know there was always that
and then like another gym and you know
yeah my when my dad would be like I'm
going you know like he would be like you
know over the 20 years there was a
handful of times where he like I'm
getting back into this and we go for
like a year or whatever and then you
know obviously fall out like most people
do yeah we were garage people I remember
my brother was the first one that you
know really start because you know he's
a couple years older started getting
into it got like this it's the classic
thin bench press uhhuh it looked like it
would fall apart it was it was like look
like it was built out of bike parts mhm
it had like sparkles on the on the like
the the cushion sure you know what I
mean mhm [__] in there with that
thing and then he got the uh the bar
that goes over the door or supposed to
go in the door frame like the perfect
pull-up type thing yeah mhm but it
wasn't that it was like a it was a
precursor to that sure yeah yeah but
neither one of us could do a pull-up
have you ever been able to do a pull-up
yeah yeah I was able to do I think two
or three for like two months in college
yeah this was probably 2
[Music]
18 maybe 17 18 I was doing pull-ups yeah
going into my sophomore year football
camp uh I had lost all all the weight
from football for for lacrosse I was
Landscaping all summer drinking not
eating couple extra curriculums sure uh
and I rolled in like a buck 75 or like a
buck 80 or something like that killed it
with the dips killed it with the
pull-ups I couldn't do a [__] pull-up
now oh I would have about 2 seconds
hanging off the helicopter I'm done I'm
not making it I could I probably I mean
I don't think you could I could hang for
a a minute I not a 60 seconds no a
minute was a not say that trainer did
wonders not a scientific sh out to
Vinnie uh yeah no that [__] that shit's
brutal that shit's [__] brutal I'd be
lucky to make it to 30 seconds sure well
they don't they do that thing like
that's like the the scam where they have
it for like if you can hang for a minute
and they get all these like you know and
but then it like turn it's like a it's
like a corny trick it rolls and like all
your and you end up [__] dropping oh
like that bar is it's rigged it's like a
board it's like the doing it at the
Wildwood Boardwalk all the [__] games
are rigged are they though on the
Wildwood Boardwalk you think those
Basketball rims were were last summer
the feds have come in and like we're
like this is highly illegal the feds
bringing the feds in for that I don't
know if it was the f but there trying to
make a goddamn living do you not
remember running through like 200 bucks
in about 15 minutes of that basetball we
were we were half drunk and [__] we
stink first thing that comes up why
would games ring State authorities have
accused Jersey Shore Boardwalk amusement
operator of rigging basketball games
with overinflated balls and display
prizes you can never win I respect it
those aren't even real jerseys by the
way they're not game
jerseys remember remember those jerseys
that they had hanging up yeah yeah yeah
they were they're not [__] game
issued yeah they so they h Hammer the
[__] rims in back in the day that
same one that we shot on hammers the
rims in and then they would spray paint
the rims and they would wrap uh black
electrical tape around the rim so it
like it [__] with your perception of it
it was like in Little Rings H they had
it like taped out and then you can never
look at the rims from the side they used
to have big pieces of wood blocking the
side angle so you couldn't see that the
rim was at like cuz you're looking at a
dead on you can't tell that it's OB yeah
but if you see from the side it's like
[__] you know it's like smooshed in
from that to that so they would block
your view from the side I mean dude that
that's as old as time sure and then I'm
sure they could come in like yeah it
goes in it does legally fit in and
there's nowhere that says like hey this
is a regulation size hoop but the ball
does fit in if it goes in perfectly you
know bastards K let's talk about true
Classics baby shout out to True Classics
and I got a 3XL announcement for you
uncle Hank fits in them let's go you
looked good too the most comfortable
t-shirt I've ever put on my body here's
the thing when I go like this the
sleeves like tighten up yeah you feel
jacked dude I'm like ready to tune
somebody up Fabric's unbelievable it's
soft goes down it's it covers everything
perfectly shout out to True Classics do
yourself a favor get over and get the
best T-shirt you're ever going to wear
and the last t-shirt you're ever going
to wear and best news yet tune you up
true Classics ain't just t-shirts no
more I don't know if you've been heard
you been away for a long time get their
active give their active wear a look
they got crew neck joggers out that have
Odor Control moisture wicking technology
so you can sweat and smell like a pig
all you want in your up but your clothes
won't uh they also got hoodie sweaters
bomber jackets and much more sweaters
are nice yeah T-Bone was rocking the
sweater the other day you'll find
something get your good sweater you'll
find something that not only looks but
feels great too true Classics is so
committed to their products they even
have 100% Perfect Fit guarantee and easy
returns so if you think you're ready to
upgrade your closet now with our
exclusive Link at true classics.com
garbage and save up to 25% off your
first order that's 25% off your first
order when you visit true
classic.com garbage make 2024 your most
stylish year yet with true Classics do
it baby do it okay let's talk about
rocket money who don't love cash let me
ask you this if I ask you right now what
subscriptions you have would you know no
cuz you're a dumbass mm but a lot of us
are we don't know what we got I fly by a
seat of my pants you know who can help
rocket money sure they could go in they
can identify what subscriptions you have
if it's something you haven't used in a
long time or you wanted to cancel Bing
it's out of here y they help you save
money they help you put money in your
pocket and help you save money yeah
three best things in the world rocket
money is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscription monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills rocket money
has over 5 million users and it's helped
save its members an average of $720 a
year hit him with the big number with
over
$500 million in cancel subscriptions you
got a couple couple f-22s for that Mai
uh it's absolutely insane it's so easy I
can see why uh you want all your
subscriptions one place if you see
something you want to cancel bada bing
bada boom all it does is take a tap uh
Gone are the days of getting on the
phone with customer service and bitching
and they put you on hold they don't put
you on hold rocket money Cuts them out
and does it uh stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions today by going to
Rocket money.com garbage that's rocket
money.com / garbage rocket money.com
garbage dooit gang now back to the show
back to the show any who that's neither
here nor there nope cuz we're here for a
what family episode just the boys the
bozos and the homies to answer your
questions as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon you have a question
read on the air by goddamn Kippy Kevin
James Ryan himself oh yeah kids half a
celebrity over here down at Boardwalk
Sam's Pizza number one customer at 10
years in a row King of the boards let's
not forget that I talk about half cele
I'm King of the [__]
boards uh all right probably the one
that ratted out the basketball guy in
the feds hey that a PE somebody's got a
fall it ain't going to be me you know
what I mean [__] paty in that thing
Dum broad had it coming hey 30% of the
Jo uh speaking of scams this is from
Mike this is a move I've never thought
of like it uh $10 Turnpike troll toll
never had one read you ever use a check
to buy a Visa gift card and a birthday
card that you throw away so you have a
little spending money till payday so the
the birthday card is this throw off the
cent of the cashier that you're not just
a dirt bag
buying so this is what he does cuz the
check's not going to clear for probably
two three days okay and so let's say he
gets paid on Friday MH he wakes up
Friday morning with money in his account
let's say it's Wednesday he's got no
cash he does have a checkbook okay that
he knows we'll buy him three days he'll
buy a $1,000 gift card or $500 gift card
and now he's got a $500 American Express
gift card he can use as cash anywhere
American Express is accepted from
Wednesday to Friday yeah so he's buying
himself and the check clear the check
even if you write the check out for that
day Wednesday it still won't really
clear until Friday at least it buys you
a day or two for sure you're floating
the check is what you're doing you're
floating but I mean that's not illegal
no frowned upon get caught you can get
caught with your hand in the cookie jar
for sure if the check doesn't clear or
something like that processed that day I
don't I don't know checks anymore you
got to do that [__] after I learned that
the hard way you got to do [__] like
that
afternoon don't be trying to [__] get
money in the morning you do that after
12:00 maybe two three there's no way
that's making the cycle by then after
banking hours I would that's when I
would do it oh there you go I'm not I'm
not I'm not floating a check before 5:00
no what where it goes from dirt bag
scheme to pro move is the birthday car
yes throw them off the scent it's my
nephew's birthday I'm I'm I'm splurging
I wanted to get him something nice he
wants an appetizer sampler and a bunch
of dollaritas at Applebees yeah he does
I'mma take him over there he's a good
kid is you're like sign you're fake
signing it it's a seven-year-old
birthday
card uh yeah that's a [__] pro move I
respect it but be careful out there I
you know as a as a man who I I don't
know when this was can you still do that
what can you still write a check write
bad checks hell yeah yeah you can still
write checks you can still do that I can
I can go into CVS and write a check I
would get eyes on that maybe not CVS I
don't know where he's doing it though
but I would I would assume most places
take personal checks you might have to
have like two forms of ID or whatever I
don't know but I'm sure can't you do
this can't you go into the
bank on a
Wednesday write a check to cash get the
cash and it doesn't hit until Friday
what wouldn't that still take a couple
no it's right away I guess it would come
right out of your account of you're [__]
yeah if you go to Year back I think
other people used to CVS does not accept
personal checks no kidding burn one too
many times yeah I bet they have uh you
can still pay with a personal check at
grocery stores had the deodorant locked
up they know what's up you can still pay
for a personal check at with a personal
check at grocery stores department
stores and more for all of them you need
a state ID a few stores will accept a
well that will accept or Hobby Lobby
Barnes and Kmart CO's Macy's Dollar Tree
hobby they're hanging on for the Home
Depot Walgreens Costco all pay with
checks really I'm going to start doing
checks that take forever though right
what do you mean I don't know for it to
hit your account yeah this is what we're
talking about it takes longer to hit
your account that you spend money you
don't [__] you don't have I like the
idea but you need that coming down the
pipeline that's the only problem yeah be
nice to start paying thing I your
check I still I I have my checkbook and
I've been using it more and more me
personally yeah no you wouldn't take a
check from me I wouldn't take a venmo
from you cash that's
good who's H schoy just accept it cancel
that right away oh yeah charge I gble to
charge back no thank you now I'm paying
for the charge back on my end yeah I
don't know this dude he took my phone
took my
[Music]
phone [__] that's a [__] pro move
though I never thought of that I never
really dabbled with checks I've only I
think I only really wrote
one early on and it bounced for like 150
bucks I had said to get in a mountain
house and it bounced and I had
to go through the whole thing so it's
like I I and they started getting phased
out so I just [__] I fell out
somewhere out there there's a guy in his
car right now who just drove past a
Hobby Lobby didn't say a word and just
pulled it yeah and buddy good
luck I'm [__] on him but that used
to be my favorite place when I was
driving the uh the laser hair removal
that was my favorite place to go and
like out in like Long Island and [__]
like that like in the BBS find a nice
strip mall that had like a [__] uh
like a model train store cuz they had
the models they had a bunch of different
thing different thing look at the trains
you had a train setup I could buy like
my little Matchbox uh like jet fighters
they had like little die cast metal
pretty cool get some real good glue for
sniffing yeah go sit in the van and
listen to Howard Stern and [__] sniff
glue after a $40 Burger King breakfast
order uh my favorite thing was I when I
worked at when I worked for that home
improvement company selling like
canvasing mhm I would go drop I was the
canvasing manager so I would drop them
all off and be like you go I'll drop you
here I would have to like print out maps
in the morning of like all right you
have you know [__] Mockingbird Lane
to here and I would like you know print
out Google Maps and highlight it for him
and go all right I'll and then like I'll
I'll drop them off and I'd go meet him
in like an hour man in that hour I would
it' be in the middle of Jersey
Pennsylvania somewhere Delaware I would
drive around and look for a strip mall
with like Anthony's Pizzeria Lorenzo
something and I would [__] F this
would be about noon after I had my Wawa
sizzly at like you know
9:30 I'd find that [__] thing and I'd
sit in there and paint a goddamn
Masterpiece I'm talking like four slices
no not even Diet Cokes just heavy bikes
like 2 or three 20 o bottles walk out
crush a heater call them and they be
like oh what have you done I'm like I
just did over I had to go meet a client
or whatever how to go meet
Antonio I'm knocking on doors seeing if
they're open meanwhile you're over on
Stromboli
Street chowing down looking back on that
though um I know being younger and doing
that remember how bad you felt after
lunch after a lunch like that how brutal
the rest of the day was with a [__]
belly full of calzone and [__] soda
and [__] coffee and I mean calzone
for lunches that's a big St I'm not
judging you but I mean that's a hefty
lunch calz you're eating four slices I'm
not throwing in shade I'm just saying no
but to fold it over is a bridge too far
it is that dough is heavier we all know
that yeah it's thick it's
thick I was doing thin crust style that
shit'll put you to sleep man holy [__]
the sausage the peppers [__] oh man I
can have the heartburn right now and
just sitting in the work van just like
dying I remember blood sugar just like a
[__] earthquake I remember I would
come home I first moved to New York I
was live with my buddy in the Heights i'
was working that shitty job I'd come
home and I stop at uh this is how fat I
was I would have to take the the bus to
the subway and I would get off the bus
and hit a pizza place like 20 blocks
from my house eat I'd Crush there and
they big heavy thick slices and every
time I walked I would do it a couple
times a week and it's bad when a guy in
your n you're you're a regular and not
in your neighborhood you know what I
mean that guy and probably I'm not even
joking had pizza for lunch too cuz I had
one out in new Ro shell too I would walk
in and he'd be like ah you know slice of
pepperoni and a slice of plane I'm like
yeah dude I would [__] I'd Munch
[__] 15 slices of pizza and I
immediately get back and fall asleep on
the couch at like 6 o00 before I went
out and did spots man that those sleeps
sweaty [__] the TV's on and you're
just like you can't help but just
[__] your brain shuts down dude
that's brutal I was I thought you were
going to do the The Walking bite I'm a
big fan of that or was a big fan of that
never walked to eat getting off the uh
the train out there in Queens if I was
done doing a wait and table shift during
the day and didn't have spots or was
going home before I went out to do spots
stop at pey's Burgers grab a burger eat
that as I'm walking down the street and
then hit the pizza place right next to
my apartment and get like a like dinner
like a chicken chicken Franz and [__]
pen Al vakka yeah and all that stuff
that's when you started getting real big
with with those those years I remember
those yeah yeah the way up is great sure
get there it ain't ain't that fun it's
Lonely at the Top you know what I mean
it's one way to put it it's the road
paved with chocolate
milk uh all right let's see here uh this
is one's from Matt is it garbage within
the first 30 seconds sitting down at a
restaurant your dad harasses the first
person in a worker uniform to go get
your waiter because happy hour ends in 8
minutes and I want to make sure I get my
order in oo man I don't disagree with
that though I thought it was going to be
bread mhm the
folies expected bread immediately sure
sure dropped the [__] bread there was
this one place that they really like the
uh they were almost like garlic knots it
was some place in amer PA that they
started going to like right after 911
like in the early 2000s they started
going
had a little bit of cash things were
going good we were out of the house I
like to go out to dinner on Thursday and
Friday night and it was like like garlic
not bread it was so I couldn't believe
they gave it to you for free mhm and man
they abused it four or five baskets yeah
and they wanted it when they pulled into
the parking lot mhm but happy hour I I
get I get I mean happy hour they're
trying to get you in there so it's like
hey man if you got me in here and your
the prices are going up in [__] 8
minutes at least let me wet my my beak
on the on the Discount Beverages I
didn't know happy hour applied to the
tables I thought happy hour was only at
the bar thought that was a bar thing no
I think happy hour if you sit down it's
happy hour it's like hey we have it's
not like every drink but it's like hey
we have [__] $2 bud you know $2
domestics and half price appetizer they
want you in there to hang out for you
know listen pal get me my margarita Stat
or it's about to be the angry hour I
just had that a wa wa when I was down
there they're doing that [__] I was like
dude I bought a bunch of stuff listen I
had a sandwich I had a bag of Doritos I
had a pack of heaters and two WWA diet
ice te the wah wa order can get can get
out of you need a suitcase that's a lot
to that's a lot to carry two drinks a
bag of chips a sandwich and heaters and
I'm like oh so he rung me up and I paid
I'm like uh can I have a bag and he's
like it's 35 cents or whatever I want to
go what am I going to walk out of here
like a [__] like a beggar with all
this stuff in my hands like I'm looting
The Joint what the [__] give me a bag
but I'll pay the 35 cents you got in
smashing Gra grab this joint you prick
what the [__] oh hey I'm K give me a bag
I'm a goddamn gentleman here I got
heaters and diet IC tea [__] what do
I look like here people people know my
business or my caloric intake hardly any
of your concerned I did spring for the
shorty not the classic by the way I was
watching my
figure even though they're expensive in
a waste grocery store those like felt
ones to like the real thin felt no like
the plastic ones like the ones that are
they're like
suitcases like the nice bags at a
grocery store oh got like the pl like
the waterproof ones yeah let's go oh I'm
all on them let's go we bu we have like
the real they're reusable but they're
like who's not throwing those out the
second it's the same [__] what no people
save those do they yeah they reuse them
huh most a couple times and then it gets
to be too many oh you ever see someone
on the subway with those things like
they're like duct taped and [__] it's
like buddy they're a nickel I'll bu go
get a new I always forget to bring mine
to the grocery store oh yeah never I buy
them every I buy them new every time I
have 700 I don't forget I'm not I'm not
doing it [__] pulling that out who am
I my mom [__] out of here riding my bike
back to the house with a baguette
sticking out of my I went I went to Acme
over the some or something I'm like yeah
how I'm going to go to Acme she's like
well stop by the house and get the bag
it was like a 10 minutes out of the way
I'm like lady I'm not adding 20 minutes
to my trip to save a doar 50 here it'll
cost me more in gas I got cash you know
what I mean that's a real trashy
statement anyway it cost you more in gas
I got to go all the way out there man
I've been hit with that a couple of
times by some uncles what are you doing
you're wasting all that gas money well
the big thing the so the Germans they
they've been on the system no bags for a
minute you bring your own bag bring your
own bag if you buy a bag there they look
at you like who the [__] do it's like
like you don't don't even have them you
know yeah and
I'm like we're buying a bag and dude my
wife I mean she'll put a can of tomato
sauce in her ass like it's like dude
they like sit there they have a table
afterwards that you go and take your
belongings to and then just start
shoving them in all your pockets and
your jackets and your if you didn't
bring your bag yeah no one wants to
bring a bag it's like they they just
stuff their pockets so you got like
cheese in there like you got some Bree
some eggs in your eggs in your shoes be
sure to wear your shopping vest yeah
that's what it is dude it's [__]
whack I'm like lady we're get in a
[__] bag like you're going on Safari
yeah for Christmas I got new shopping
trousers it's it's like when it's like
when Karen Hill went into jail to visit
him dude it's like all coming he's got
salami in her coat and [__] I'm like get
the [__] out of here remember late 9s
early 2000s when like good people like
environmental people started like doing
that showing up with their own bag and
[__] I was I was I was a the ridicule
they I I was a cashier and man I didn't
even like touching their bags some lady
coming in with natural deodorant on
crusty
hippies you're such a dirt bag you're
making the wrong reference you're like
look at Isaac Newton over
here hey Benjamin Franklin what are you
trying to save the planet hey Helen
Keller nice burlap sack HH [__]
scumbags oh man look at this dude it was
two the year was 2003 into four working
at Acme in New Town Pennsylvania I would
assume not a lot of people that would do
that were shopping at Acme no they were
new Town's a nicer area I'm saying
that's real Whole Foods vibe there was
no Whole Foods back there like
that and was a Fresh Field that was a
that was a higher end Acme and they
would come in and man you could tell
when they were like three people back in
your line you're like this is an own
bagger we got here [__] what they got
their own
bags yo check out C Planet over there
meanwhile I'm triple plastic I smelled
your patruli stink when you walked in
meanwhile I'm like oh what are you
getting the milk let's put five plastic
bags around that have a nice day you
want double triple triple plastic I got
you that was the thing when you moved to
New York triple baging somebody sigs hey
don't want them getting wet on you make
sure you throw them in the
drain make sure you burn them in the
backyard terrible get those chloro floro
garbage out there oh man yeah um the
Pathfinders now look at it it's it's
yeah it's the norm it's the [__] Norm
especially in New York I don't know how
many can you see how many states have
banned uh cuz Jersey did it I don't
think PA did it I don't I don't miss the
plastic bag they are they are whatever I
like those ones at the store the
application of the plastic bags and
other things is great you got a wet
bathing suit a plastic bag is great you
got dir shoes a plastic bag is great the
TR you know for the recyclables all that
it the application of it is fantastic
yeah at the hotel I started using the uh
the bag that The that's in the bucket of
ice sure for my wet bathing suit fold it
up and put it in there right in the
suitcase I don't know if I've ever told
you this I saw my cousin one time used I
might have used the pillowcase for his
shoes his like shoes were dirty to put
in his luggage took it from the hotel
yeah damn proba whack you out for that
they don't know you don't think wow
they're missing a pillowcase 18 states
of banned plastic bags there you go
that's it Hawaii New York Delaware
Colorado Illinois Minnesota Washington
Massachusetts Florida Maryland Oregon
California Maine Connecticut Vermont
Arizona District DC and New Jersey no
[__] that's it
18 that's almost half yeah it takes a
long time to [__] to enact that [__]
there somebody somebody's getting
greased on that holding that off a
little bit in a couple of States oh for
don't hate wait before we get to this
next question I have something something
I wanted to ask you fellas tell you know
what makes you feel like a real dirt bag
and the situation I'm currently in at
the moment having to use your phone as
the remote to your TV wa that's no good
first of all it's amazing that you even
know how to use that
technology that's crazy you download an
app it's it's relatively easy but I got
jammed up because if you showed my mom
that her head would explode I couldn't
turn the TV on yep so I was like oh my
remote had been [__] up so I shipped I
got a new one but I get seven days so
I'm like all right I'll I'll work I'm a
smart guy I own a business I'll do a
workaround I download the app but the
TV's got to be on so I can't then I had
the app and couldn't turn the [__] TV
on oh and then I had they finally well
the [__] hellhound that chewed the
remote so it does everything but turn
the TV on you can turn the TV on but
it's not it you don't have to hit the
power button I don't want to explain it
cuz it'll make me sound like such a nerd
but I think it has to be on at it
probably can but in order for to link
the remote you you to the from in order
to link the app to the TV the TV has to
be
on yes but there's a way to wake the TV
but it's it's like on the remote app it
has a power button that only will turn
it off it won't turn it on you have to
like go to reconnect device and then
when you do that it wakes the TV up and
then you go back into the remote that
was so I feel like such a failure sh
sucks wakes the TV it's no good it's
been weeks that's a bad the bird has it
on her phone where she has this thing on
the lights where she can turn off the
lights in the hallway on her phone oh
she's probably just talking to
ghosts Uncle Charles scared the [__] out
of me one night I was out there [__]
brushing my teeth sh the strob blade on
yet thought I was stroking out I
immediately jump into it I can start
going in I was brushing my teeth in my
[__] skibbies and I come out of the
bathroom and she [__] hits the lights
on me from the room I thought it was
[__]
mhm thought it was it thought it was
Jeeper Creepers getting me the ban or
whoever it was we got that in the BBS we
can [__] we got everything linked up
to the phones to you could flick them on
now click them on now turn the heat on
turn the air on I'd be doing that all
the time mhm just in case do you
remember when the remote start for the
car hit oh remember it was aftermarket
my stepdad had the aftermarket one it
had it own clicker and you'd see someone
with two clickers you go guy's got a
little bit of cash on
him it's got an auto body guy MH yeah no
one in my family ever had that we were
into cold cars exclusively sure my
parents loved it once it became Factory
sure they weren't aftermarket what no
yeah are you kidding me yeah yeah my mom
loved it well she they were also big
fans of going out and warming up the car
that was a big Foley move you go out
there you [__] before you get dressed
like before you like you have you're
ready to go before you my dad put on his
nebor uniform my mom put on her uh
whatever
tassels whatever she want to work they'
go out there scrape the car [__] turn
it on the MC mullen's never once pre
that the original cold plunge getting in
that car going to school dude ice cold
yeah how long did it take that [__]
car my Chevy Lumina that I had all 1995
5 four six Chevy Lumina whatever the
[__] it was 95 Chevy
Loom um by the time I got to school it
still wasn't blowing hot air that Sig
sucked cuz you're like I got the window
open but it's colder inside than it is
outside riing eaters on the way to
school God yeah you weren't no I was
[__] an athlete coming out a [__]
wrestling what was his
[Laughter]
name was he
tender he's a sweet lover did he talk to
you in
public it was one night Henry get over
it your fat ass doing tonight
nothing oh yeah cold dude yeah sigs on
sigs before school for sure and when I
got when after I crashed that car I
didn't have a car for a while uh sigs at
the bus stop no I would get picked up
from school sigs out front and I would
close the garage all right Denise I'll
see I knew she had to hop in the shower
so I would just [__] close the garage
door and I'd stand in a blind spot crank
a heater boom flick it if there was snow
I had at least a couple of weeks so I
had to deal with
that then keep it moving you know the
thing we did we got to take care of it I
know the birds will eat it uh were you
two are you guys too young for anybody
smoking on the school bus what yeah yeah
no yes no seventh and eighth grade no
way no not like smoking like they're on
a flight sneaking heaters in the back
with the windows down the bad kids oh
okay I thought I thought it was open no
like asking the driver for a light and
[__] teach you believe they just raised
M Bros again that's
[__] I got a bad cough let me bum a
cigarette will you let me get one of
them Chester fields from you young man
yeah no no like a couple of dirt bag
kids we were on the back of the bus did
no one have a sense of smell till like
1997 yeah cuz everybody was smoking
everywhere everybody was smoking it
didn't matter everybody was smoking
everywhere you were just used to it the
one stairwell of my high school red of
heaters yeah we didn't have Rak it would
crush you when you walk that was the big
thing too like I was smoking like
smoking in the boys like in the bathroom
I think like one kid tried it and like
the smoke alarm went like you couldn't
pull that off anymore no your kids were
still one my boys my boy was was was
huffing heaters he'd come in dizzy cuz
he would do like three or four major
pool
and then walk in all loopy I know like
you just hit the dust off can uhhuh
that's an all right
feel [__] sitting in science class I
like
it I like that that that that sick
feeling in my stomach uh all right let's
see here this is from OIC burps $10
cappo never had one read are you garbage
of your parents Christmas presents that
this is what he bought for his parents M
are work boots for Mom and an ounce of
hash for Dad that's what they asked
for man where do you get hash these days
where you announce of hash
2024 holy [__] you got to go to the Far
East you got to import that dude yo I
haven't seen hash in legit a decade yeah
and even I have at the Waffle House
[__] chop up let's go even that's
crazy cash 10 years ago was rare what
Dash in 1978 was fck I know that's what
I'm saying we went through a baby phase
of that smoking hash a little bit of
reef for sure we're all gentlemen here
it's legal Andor decriminalized in most
areas this guy's still shaking off n huh
that guy has faded tattoos bro and
[__] demons yeah you're hitting the
[__] pipe whoa that's crazy I don't
even know what hash really is it's uh I
I'll look it up but it looks like
brownie it's pressed I know that it's
it's like pressed just press THC right I
don't I don't I I genuinely don't know
I've never smoked it I mean it was so
the handful like the hippie kids who
were into like fish and the dead and
stuff like that they would get their
hands on it like I got his I'm like all
right well I don't want to talk to you
for a week keep it
moving take your opium and beat it yeah
dude I got [__] I got heaters to
catch I need you [__] dipping out on
me [__] going night
night hash oil man he take that meong
Delta [__] and [__] beat it hand me a
Budweiser you commi
bastard smoke flour in these parts young
Mexican brick weed you want to smoke the
devil's lettuce that you hey to eat your
own but you're not going to stand here
and smoke hash you [__] communist
Chinese Ash in front of me hear that
Poppy Pete get out of my [__] face
okay so the way you make hash is you
remove the uh the the active parts of
the bud like so like the when you have a
really nice nug and it looks like it's
all snowed on you basically get all that
off the bud to ke yeah is ex sure and
then 's getting flagged and then you
sure and then you uh press it and makes
an oil uh no no no no it hardens it it's
like you jam it and then it compounds
yeah that's real drug [__] like not not
against it but I'm just saying that's
man your dad wants an ounce an ounce
that's a brick that's crazy look up how
volume wise oh yeah cuz that's compact
see what an ounce of hash looks like can
you you know what I mean let me see if I
can find it and if there's still any
Warlords in La that we can go score
that's crazy here I found one on
Reddit oh it's not that much but that's
got to last you a long time it just
looks like a little uh one of those
little B one of those little bites those
little brownie bites the John man those
things are all right yeah dude a corner
of that you'd be on the
moon man dude your dad smoking hash
that's wild holy [__] man yeah talk
about stuck in the
70s I smoke get some fentanyl or
something dude I smoked hash spliffs in
Spain and they would really crack when
you PLL them oh man
God that shit's wild man that they're
wild Christmas presents for your parents
that's what's on their list that's
what's
uh they didn't break your balls about
the PlayStation 5 that you wanted
probably sure pair of work boots and
some [__] brick also work boots for
mom is a wild that's that's also very
telling first of all that your hippie
your hippie ass Dad should get a job and
let let ma take take a day off in the
factory take a tooke off the as this
girl's going to [__] work all day
he's he's [__] you know oh can you
imagine shaking someone's Mom's hand and
being like ah God good
over the dad's like hey
man you smoke ass your mom's got rough
hands bro what [__] dude imagine if
you you walked into a guy you walked
into your buddy's house to meet his
parents or your your you know your
girlfriend's parents or whatever and the
dad's I just picture like the beaded
[__] door and stuff and he's male
pattern baldness into a ponytail he's
just there [__] getting ripped you
want to hit of this man oh what is it
the joint hash man what the [__] year is
it hey atrax get the [__] out of my
face oh God me S blun you that's wild
that's wild I didn't even like parents
back in the day it was obviously
different and all that like it's changed
but knowing parents that would smoke
weed in front of their who kind of like
openly smoked weed that was weird to me
it's like buddy man get your [__] to go
to a PTA meeting do something yeah over
here smoking blunts you don't how to
make it
Manhattan the [__] that held you grow up
lady [__] girl je that was a home run
of a question man uh all right this
one's from Friday night Habachi what are
your thoughts on my parents running
industrial margarita machine for my high
school graduation party my dad did it
and I broke a lamp and had to be put to
bed by 10:00
man
those those margarita machines will ruin
a party it'll be great for about 90
minutes n they're awesome man and then
someone's swinging on somebody someone's
falling in the pool a lamp's getting
broken dude that is one of my favorite
things on the planet frozen margarita a
strong frozen margarita I [__] love
them it's all right dude I don't [__]
disagree a cherry and a lime and some
salt on the rim heavy bike that's what
I'm talking about that's like when we
were down in Florida we went to like a
one of those beach bar like a fat
Tuesday kind of thing and they had like
the margarita wall or something and it
was like you know 50 of them on there
and you're like I'll do a tropical thing
I'll do a burton Ernie let me do a
whatever whatever man I have sucking
those things down getting a sugar rush
and a brain freeze but getting twisted
felt like I was smoking hash their
slogan is home of the world's fastest
hangover oh that's sugar the next day
Sunday scaries um in Stereo [__] Jam
you up H that brought up um something
that I wanted to touch on a little bit
I'm listening there was that period from
especially if your family partied if
your family were drinkers you know what
I mean you had a big family extended
family there was that window
I would say between somewhere in high
school
till maybe sophomore junior year of
college where there was always a cousin
or maybe you it happens to the best of
us that overdid it at a family thing got
[__] up had to be put to bed or taken
away by a dad or an uncle started crying
[__] to bed threw up said something
[__] up
you know yeah we uh we had a couple of
those uh yeah we I've I I've told the
story my cousin Shawn got all [__] up
at a Thanksgiving and I told you this he
had like the platter of like the turkey
or whatever or the he ended up sitting
on the table like a table like this and
he thought he was off he was off
probably on hash or something he thought
he was driving the B like he thought he
was driving a bus and he was like all
aboard or whatever like I guess he was
having fun or whatever a bit Yeah but it
I mean it was thanks Thanksgiving Day
table yeah or Christmas dinner and
everybody like what the [__] you got
that [__] up dinner I was talking like
a graduation party or something like
that oh yeah we so we would always party
afterwards so like we'd all be wherever
we were with the family everybody's
having two three beers the kids are it's
like all right the kids are allowed to
start having beers or the parents are
looking the other way and then they
would the parents or the kids would all
go somewhere and continue the party on
their own that's when it got you know
Kevin and Danny got into it Steve and
Billy got into it I'm talking at the
party in front of like relatives we had
a couple of things like that
luckily I did all that stuff on the low
with friends in private circles I'd get
I'd get [__] up and embarrassed myself
there but I got away with never doing it
at a family thing like being the cousin
that you know got [__] up and you know
threw up or whatever sure I did do it at
my friend's house in front of his family
at a graduation party
black blackout drunk [__] doing a
dice impersonation
oh in their living room I ended up
peeing all over their their their powder
room yeah I had a buddy pee on my mom's
TV one time and then wanted to fight me
afterwards like you know blacked out
woke up to her credit his mom was cool
as [__] about it yeah it would be cool
too I think if like it's like yeah
you're 18 and you're I was in eighth
grade
I
hey go see if your dad's got any hat
let's party that's when we started
sneaking beers I I I worked that night
and they had they had this huge
graduation party and [__] line the
[__] bottom of his of his dresser
drawer with uh trash bags iced it down
and just slowly throughout the night
just poaching them yeah couple couple
couple my dad my my dad would have they
had a bar set up in the house always but
they had the like regular crazy they had
like regular you know bottles of liquor
but he would buy the handle of whatever
brand so if he had like a bottle of
smear knoff he'd have a handle that he
would refill that bottle with right
that's keeping up appearances gentlemen
yeah but it was perfect for me cuz then
I'm going in the pantry sneaking shots
all day long I finally told him like two
years ago and he was like I knew I
wasn't drinking that fast I mean I was
going through a handle a day I mean I'm
good but not that good they had a a bar
set up all the time your PE they didn't
have that at the Pie's house right uh a
bar setup no we were there were they
were wine and beer drinkers it's like I
mean there was constantly always a
bottle of Ni wine yeah sure in the
fridge in the fridge that's also how you
know you know she's got NY wine Danny's
got NY wine my sister has n wine and now
I at in the BBS I also we keep cuz it's
like I know I'm going to have to get it
if she's coming over she comes over she
wants a glass of wine so it's like we
got three three of the Magnum bottles in
the in the in the C I have have what she
Barefoot is that what she likes no uh
Cavit
Pino
Cavit Cavit I do a bottle I do a glass
of Peno what's the Peno comes with two
scratchers and a Goldberg
chew do you have those did you you know
what a Goldberg chew is no funny combo
words yeah wait to shoot yourself in the
foot you should have just took the laugh
will you get that I love them yeah um we
got to wrap it up gang what a fun one
yeah this was a hoot yeah gang we love
you to death we can't thank you enough
excited for
2024 um as the uh the Bold one said get
over there grab your tickets to Town
Hall May 9th come out and see the boys
there in New York City and uh pick up a
few uh get a pack of cards yep ay second
version of the ru garbage card game we
love you very much and we'll see you
next week peace